okay another another new thing to talk
about is Wolfram script so Wolfram
script is a command line way of of
interacting with Wolfram language so you
can say so you can either use it locally
on your machine or you can say run it in
the cloud so I can show you that if we
go back to the terminal window I was
doing this with we can say Wolfram
script - cloud - code let's say 100
factorial okay so what this will now do
is it will run as a command line program
it will run it will take 100 factorial
will send it to the cloud it's been
authenticated it will send back the
results so that's a useful thing if
you're building this into a script that
in a large system you can also take that
let me show you you can also do that
with you can create kind of a shell
function and you can where you can then
call it with come up with with arguments
and the shell and you can basically use
the same mechanism that you use for it
probably has examples here you can use
the same mechanism basically that you
create an API so here we're creating a a
Wolfram script function with signature
city city that computes the distance
between two cities and we can now deploy
that as a command line thing and then we
give the on the command line we give
these two cities and it will return to
the directly to the shell the the result
okay so there are lots of different ways
to integrate Wolfram language into into
things it's a you can if you look at
this a kind of horrendously complicated
page of the ways that that you can
integrate the Wolfram engine either sort
of inside your other application or as
the shell outside an application there
are a lot of different forms of
deployment that exist but so one thing
that Tim let's talk about external
languages so one one big thing that's
come in version 11 point two is the
ability to let's go here
is the ability to actually send
computations directly from within well
from language to external programs and
that's not a good sign
that's really odd um let's try this
again no let's try it again hmm
well I dissolved let me try one thing
here let's try doing I've got one more
idea if I might make that work let's try
here and let's try its just try external
evaluate in Python of let's say 34 to
the power 5 or something oh I want that
in a string that'll probably 34 to the
power 5 and wake up oh it uses it's an
exclusive or operator
I bet Python doesn't Python uses wedges
and it's loose of or operator okay well
anyway let that's but in any case what
this is doing is it's running that
computation from this string it's
running that as a effectively through a
Python R Apple to get the results so
there's a way that you can immediately
integrate Python code into end to orphan
language and it's a very kind of
lightweight way to do that okay so and
what's non-trivial about it is being
able to do all the type conversions and
so on for things that are coming back
from from the computation okay and we
have right now an eleven point two we
support Python and JavaScript lots of
other languages are coming and it's it's
kind of a way what we will be doing in
the future is supporting not just a wrap
all where you're using an interactive
language but also external function
which calls directly into functions and
external languages which allows one to
deal with languages that can't have
rebels and that's kind of a more
streamlined and lightweight way to do
what we can currently do with WS DP and
word library link and so on okay well
let me show you something now now I've
shown you a bunch of things that exist
in version 11.2 let me now jump to the
sort of the future and talk about some
what what is possible in what will be
possible in future versions so here
here's a cool thing we can if you just
type if you type an equal sign if we're
gonna have a line you get at Wolfram
Alpha cell if you type a greater than
sign up we're getting of the line you
get an external language cell and so
this right now I'd set it to default to
Python it right now just allows Python
and nodejs but now I could type in my I
wonder what it does like this if uh I
could type that in and now I just
compute that and now that's Python input
generating Wolfram language output and I
could just have pasted it in some great
big long Python program here right into
my notebook and I can be using the
notebook environment to deal with
external languages so and there are lots
of so there will be lots of convenient
things coming of different versions of
languages with all sorts of libraries
pre-installed and so on okay well you
this kind of thing we're not going to
let you do this in our public cloud to
use external languages because it
doesn't that the sandbox of our public
cloud won't allow that but if you have a
private cloud you will be able to do
this kind of thing and this sort of
brings me to talking about private
clouds so I'm the thing that terms let's
take a look here so as many of you may
know in addition to our public cloud we
also support private clouds that run in
virtual machines and when you get a
private cloud it this is the thing that
you get that allows you to set up your
private cloud this is the private cloud
enterprise private cloud configuration
notebook you get some kind of sense of
what's involved in setting up a private
cloud so there's the base domain there's
all kinds of nodes web subdomains it's a
little bit complicated it's it's
something you you can hit default for
everything but that's probably not what
you want that's setting up mail that's
setting up accounts for your users
setting up various things of databases
that are used inside it
setting up various things to do with the
way the the kernel pools work in the
cloud how the kernel is initialized what
kind of limits there should be on the
computations all this kind of things
security of wolf-men gene how the
sandbox works etc etc etc whether you
will allow people to run external code
what the branding should look like all
these kinds of things
but what's neat is you know once you go
through this notebook at the end of the
notebook you basically just press go we
generate the configuration files install
them in virtual machine restart system
services and there you have a completely
configured private cloud that will run
in your corporate environment and this
is we've been steadily streamlining this
and working with lots of customers
including some who here to build out
different configurations of the private
cloud with various kinds of elastic
versions and so on but it's it's now
become a quite streamlined thing that
just arrives as a big virtual machine
one thing that is new here oh I might
mention for private clouds one thing
that's coming yeah but one big thing
about private clouds is that we are you
can kind of cut away a lot of the
overhead that exists in the public cloud
so for example if you remove
authentication you move HTTP layers
things like that you can you can make it
faster and faster so right now the big
the big test for us is what's the time
for a minimal API call the answer right
now is 51 milliseconds that will
decrease somewhat further actually we
have another product that is coming
called Wolfram engine for web servers
which is for people who are who are
really wanting to work right down at the
kind of bare metal it's kind of the
successor to web Mathematica it has no
user authentication no cloud object
system none of the kind of structure
just raw files and that we one can
expect to do an API call in maybe 20
milliseconds or below it's worth
remembering that HTTP handshakes take
about 100 milliseconds so that's that
Dwarfs the time that it's taking to do
to do these these actual API calls now
in our cloud talking about API calls one
of the one things are important about a
private cloud is if you are running an
API in a private cloud and the API has a
lot of initialization it has to do you
can always have a kernel that has the
all that initialization pre done so when
the API needs to be called it can
immediately operate one thing that's
coming that we actually have have
working now again it's slightly
sophisticated thing is kernel forking so
that you can actually take the running
kernel
after initialization and for kit and
then you have a forked process that will
restart and not use extra not use the
the not reuse memory and so on when when
the fourth process starts and for us is
really important for operating our
public cloud but it's also it's also
really important for from alpha to be
able to use forked kernels like that
it's also important for security and
other purposes something else that's
coming in private clouds that cloud the
cloud connector for Excel being able to
go into Excel and sort of immediately
call Wolfram language functions in a
private cloud from within Excel
another thing that's coming is our HPC
cloud so this is something that let me
see if I can show you one quick example
of that oh don't tell me I don't have
that um maybe this is it um so this is
now a ok so this is now going to a test
cluster that is running great
it doesn't ok well I'll tell you what
that you would have seen if it had gone
there that's a private cloud that's been
configured with multiple cores multiple
machines and it is running parallel
computation in the cloud so that I can
use all of the parallel computation
capabilities of Wolfram language in this
private cloud and so that's a and so we
expect there will be service providers
that will set up large parallel
computation clouds that you can access
for example directly from the desktop
and just say ok I want to run in a
thousand kernels this particular
computation we now have the
infrastructure to do that ok so gosh so
many things to talk about it's yeah
there's there's all kinds of things
related to so we have a general
mechanism called kernel connection
manager which is a way of managing
machines that put possible kernels that
you can run so an example of that is
remote evaluate you can use remote
evaluate if you have a network of
raspberry pi's or something each one has
a name you can just call remote evaluate
to run current image or something on
each of those raspberry PI's there's
also a remote run function that uses SSH
another thing that's coming is genuine
standalone apps from Wolfram language so
this is an example of deploying a
standalone app to through Wolfram script
and that app we can now we could now
just run that app on the command-line
this is essentially a Wolfram script API
function a shell API function that's
been created here that we can run on the
command line the really interesting
thing about this is you'll be able to
deploy apps that start user interfaces
as well as just doing computations so
you'll be able to say bring up a
notebook make it fullscreen it's this
notebook it has these menu
configurations so you'll be able to have
something where just from the command
line effectively you are running
directly a orphan language back to app
so let's see gosh I have I have an awful
lot to talk about here let's try and
speed up a little bit so for that kind
of standalone deployment things that are
coming continuous tasks so you can have
a Raspberry Pi that's just continually
running a computation and responding to
two inputs and it will restart if the
thing reboots and so on there's also
triggered tasks which allows you upon
some trigger that comes through a
channel in the channel framework perform
a task other things for sort of embedded
computation we now have as a developer
product the ability to support Linux arm
systems other than Raspberry Pi we've
actually had android kernels for a long
time although not officially released
and now we have the system on iOS
another thing of interest to some people
we now have a headless front-end running
under Lux so in the past when you've had
to create images rasterized output you
have to be somewhere running a Windows
system that's no longer the case another
kind of external interaction that's
coming is mail search so being able to
connect to a mail server and being able
to treat your mail as kind of a set of
symbolic objects
that you can search or do computations
delete process in various ways it's kind
of complementary to the thing we've had
for a while male receiver function which
is kind of the the API function that is
activated by sending mail to a
particular address mentioning search and
other things happened is text search has
gotten a lot stronger
it's really quite an industrial-grade
search system at this point there's kind
of this pipeline of going from the
original document extracting features
indexing using signals to feed to
ranking functions and so on it's
something where we can make use of a lot
of our machine learning capabilities to
do that to do that very well we actually
just started using our own text search
for our documentation search soon it
will be running on our whole website it
will also be running in the in the cloud
to search files that people have been
storing in the cloud we also soon will
be bringing out a web crawl
functionality for crawling large
websites and crawling the web in general
something that new topic so I talked
about the thing we call the resource
system it's a way of storing stuff sort
of persistent stuff in the cloud with
metadata and convenient access so people
may know of our data drop which is a way
of incrementally adding data to data
bins the this April we released our data
repository and just bring that up so the
data repository is it's something I've
been sort of wanting to make for a
decade a place where people can put data
and make it actually useful the you know
it's very common to find some you know
paper which says and our data is
available from blah blah blah you
actually go there and it doesn't
actually work so the goal of our data
repository is to have a place where
people can publish data and have it
actually be useful and so that's really
been made possible we have this I have
to have a big stack of technology to
make that work to really enable the sort
of data back publication we need this
whole data ontology and we need to be
able to put things into a
a useful form and I mean if we actually
go here we'll go this is a particular
piece of data we could say pick up that
data let's go here this is now going to
load in the data from that particular
resource this is about meteorite
landings maybe I could take a random
sample of 500 of those and let me take
their coordinates and now I'll be just
getting the stator get a bunch of
coordinates there maybe I could do a Geo
list plot find out where those
meteorites landed and there we get the
results and this all just works we were
able to just take this data in start
processing it we've got about six
hundred entries in the data repository
so far we hope people including people
here will contribute a lot more entries
to the data repository it's this kind of
a sort of a story behind let's see the
the sort of the question of okay so when
you when you make one of these data
repository entries you can actually here
let me let me just show you how you
create a a new entry in the data
repository we just go to file new and it
says data resource and we'll then get
this big thing that you fill out that
specifies how the data resource is going
to be set up it's not very difficult to
fill this out the and then when you
press GO you can either deploy it to
submit it as a new resource
and so you can actually deploy it as a
private data resource for yourself
living in the cloud and you can access
it yourself
or you can say I want to actually submit
it to be as a public data resource so
you say resource submit that will get
sent to us and we will do some curation
and and then publish that data resource
and then the so a way to think about
this the way I've kind of thought about
this is there's some there's kind of a
hierarchy of levels of of data curation
that you need to go through it goes from
sort of the data is in digital form to
things like things like
dates and coordinates or so on are in
canonical form to things where more
sophisticated entities are in canonical
form eventually to where you get
something that is suitable for really
smooth operation as an integrated part
of wolfmann language but the idea of
data repository is if you get to about
level 5 on here you will have something
that is really useful in the data
repository and the idea is that if you
know your data and you know or from
language it should take you only about
half an hour to get your data to this
level 5 in this hierarchy and to be able
to submit it to the data repository and
there's kind of a there's this whole
sort of art of data curation that we're
interested in we've been trying to work
on creating kind of a certified data
curator program and we've been we've
been doing things in this kind of
towards this art of data curation here a
few lifes videos of showing things about
data curation ok so what one thing to
say about the data repository it's a
completely open thing so you can if you
if something is published there you can
freely download it in JSON excel format
whatever it's typically more useful and
more from language format but the idea
is to make to have it be a public
resource where people can publish data
ok so for example I've been I've been
putting lots of sort of the backup
material from new kind of Science in
there so for instance if I if you take a
particular page and so the typical
workflow will be you look at a page in a
paper the page and paper this happens to
be my new kind of science book the page
will have a link to a notebook and that
notebook will then link to a data
repository entry so here's one that
links from that page there and then you
can just go and do computations based on
the material that was in the paper ok
one thing that I mention is the notion
of entity stores so not only can one
have data sets that's a common way of
representing data there are also entity
stores an entity store is a more
sophisticated form of more sophisticated
way to deal with data so it's something
for our in-house for an internal curated
data this is now asking for the
populations of the ten most populous the
the ten most popular cities in the world
that's using essentially entity store
syntax now we can we can go to our data
repository here's an entity store of
books in my library as it turns out and
so we can go and and make use of that of
that entity store here so there's the
entity store represented like that we
have to tell it we want to add this to
our list of entity stores now we can say
for example how many books are there in
my library okay that's less than I
thought actually but the okay so we
cannot say what properties do we know
about those books so we could say for
example what is this this is doing some
computation about some making a
histogram of dates of publication years
I guess of books in my library so so
that's an example of how entity stores
work it's sort of a more a richer way of
representing data well so one of the
things that we're also dealing with is
external databases so this is dealing
with data that's directly and Morphin
language something that's coming is much
richer integration of external databases
so we've had database link for a long
time this is now truly true integration
of external databases so let's connect
to an external database here this is
this is actually our bugs database that
I connected to which is a my sequel
database we have a now a highly
optimized mechanism for generating
queries that take a little while to warm
itself up here to get ready to deal with
the new data database but now what I
should be able to do let me let me get
this ready I should be able to do things
like count the number of closed bugs
that's let's wait for this to it'll just
take a little while to get all of its
compile all of its connectivity and so
on information but then what I should be
able to do is to start doing
computations okay there we go so now
let's count the number of closed bugs
217,000 close bugs in our database let's
look at the properties of closed bugs
okay those are properties in the in the
tables that represent in our my sequel
database so this is this is completely
determined from the my sequel database
there's no there's no connector other
than just specifying how to get to that
database so for example I could say
let's look at open bugs let's look at a
summary of the top thousand first
thousand open bugs I could say for
example I could ask and now I know I'm
seeing what I'm starting to see here is
this entity store syntax so this is now
asking for the entity value of a let's
make let's make a data set out of that
this is now asking for bugs reported by
me as a function of time so this is in
version two this is a particular bug
there okay there are 39 of these bugs in
version 2 reported by me we can go
through and look at them so this is this
is what it's going to start to look like
when you do this is what a pretty
sophisticated SQL query this turns into
underneath its compiled into an SQL
query that's optimized for the
particular database that is the
underlying database but now at a
symbolic level in Morphin language you
can write arbitrarily complex database
queries and execute them against an
external database so that's a that's a
that's a neat coming attraction another
thing so they're different different
kinds of databases here's another one
we're supporting his spotl databases
triple stores so this is let me see I've
got um let's let's do something in a
triple store here so this is an
in-memory I'm just going to create a
triple store here in memory with 43
triples and now I could for example ask
for I can I have a function graph cases
which is kind of integrated with our
pattern language and it's asking in this
graph what are instances of things which
go from compound to disease this is some
kind of medical data data set in in four
steps and this is then giving the
results so it's kind of matching things
on this graph database I could also do
the same thing with an external database
this is taking a wiki data external
sparkl endpoints and now I'm running a
computation on that external sparkl
endpoint okay I mentioned before the the
neural net repository that's just an
example of another thing that is I
should mention that in addition to
things like sparkle there's also support
for
[ __ ] and s3 and things like this
okay so resource system there are we
have now have a general framework for
creating these resource systems there
are many that are coming I mentioned the
data repository mentioned the neural net
repository one that's coming next is our
function repository and the idea there I
hope it will be useful to many people
here the idea there is to be able to
basically put functions into the cloud
for anybody to be able to use let me
show you roughly how that works
you will be able to have a resource
object that's named just like in the
data repository so there's a gray code
function that has been put in the
function repository now we can have a
resource function that resource function
will look like that and now we can take
that resource function and for example
apply it to some argument and now it'll
run the code that it got from the cloud
and run that locally and this is a way
of being able to have a large library of
additional functions that can be defined
in addition to the function repository
another one that's coming is the formula
repository this is something where it's
let me show you an example so the
formula repository actually has on the
shingles in the cloud here's one for
Ohm's law that's actually you can
actually do the computation right there
in the cloud this is something for
representing formulas which typically
have a few named parameters and get a
result
another thing that's becoming part of
the resource system is the
demonstrations project so the
demonstrations project with its eleven
thousand demonstrations each one of
those demonstrations becomes a resource
object so this is just a reemployment
ation of this is a new look for the
demonstrations project that involves
that that involves some that has
demonstrations that can be run directly
in the cloud but this is now a resource
object from the demonstrations project
so this is now taking the object taking
that demonstration and having it so it's
directly loadable inter-war from
language as a piece of computable data
so it's a very convenient way to make
use of the demonstrations
object okay I'm rushing here I'm gonna
show you a few more things a bunch more
things on so this is now some sort of
research that we're doing on I'm
changing topics now I'm talking about
actually I should mention there are
other before I say that I should mention
there are other repositories that are
coming there will be an API repository
and among other things which will allow
you to among other things sell api's
sell access to api's actually you'll be
able to sell functions as well that's a
complicated story of authentication and
so on we ourselves will have a library
of what we call dead-simple api's that
will be in sort of immediate access to
specific functions within the Wolfram
language okay so here I have a sample
data set about the Titanic let me show
you something that um oh gosh I should
have started this and let me show you
something here that um that we are
working towards being able to do which
is natural language queries of data sets
so this is a particular data set that
has a few names of things here and we're
telling it that okay that we've got
passengers that we're dealing with here
so now we can make a semantic query
against this semantic data set and we
can say give us older than 70 males and
I could I could put in all kinds of
different natural language here and it's
leveraging our natural language
understanding stack to be able to do
database queries and data set queries
using natural language so that's kind of
a nice thing that's that's coming that's
sort of a junior version of what we've
been doing for a while that's a very
very serious big big thing which is
enterprise versions of Wolfram Alpha and
so the we have built custom versions of
Wolfram Alpha for a bunch of large
organizations quite a few of them are
running in production right now inside
systems that a lot of people use in the
world some people here I know from
companies that that make use of that
actually our our enterprise Wolfram
Alpha business is a separate business
unit now now I won't talk about it in in
great detail here but it's a
application of Wolfram language and kind
of a sign of what can be done there's a
the typical use case the most common
case is to build the most common
situation is CEO of large company X sees
wolf malphur and says I wish I could do
something similar with my internal data
whatever that is of doing natural
language input and being able to
generate reports based on internal data
so for the last several years we've been
building such systems custom versions
above malphur for companies that
typically combine their internal
proprietary data with public data to
come up with useful conclusions one of
the things that happens I think I think
Wolfram Alpha Enterprise Wolfram Alpha
is kind of the the the the best example
of enterprise AI that actually works I
mean typically in in companies things
have been optimized to the point where
there is that the data is quite
structured but what's a and what's not
so structures the questions you ask
about that data and that's what we're
really supporting with Enterprise
Wolfram Alpha so there'll be a bunch of
announcements actually soon about
enterprise wolf alpha about deployments
and partnerships and so on
eventually the enterprise wolf mal for
business will soak up an infinite number
of certified data curators but that's
that's a different story so ok I won't
talk about consumer wolf alpha very much
except to say that it's gotten faster
and gotten to do more things we've got a
lot of new api's that are for wolf alpha
that are convenient for deploying it a
bunch of a bunch of different ways of
having very very simple to use api's
form alpha including a new one
conversational API there's also another
thing that's happening is we are getting
foreign language versions of both novel
we've actually had a Chinese version of
Wolfram Alpha for a number of years but
for very tiresome regulatory reasons we
have been unable to deploy it but now we
have I can't type the actual input for
this but this is a japanese version of
wolf malphur that will be coming out
soon it will also be coming out in
several other languages we're at least
initially emphasizing the math component
of Wolfram Alpha to support students in
different countries this is this is the
one in Japanese be more exciting if I
could type Japanese input but I can't um
the so okay so then let's see well
that's a lot of other things happening
lots of new machine learning things
learning distributions lots of lots of
things there let me let me show you one
example of a coming attraction in in
machine learning let me go ahead and get
the the beginning of the article about
rhinoceroses from Wikipedia and now what
I can do this is a new function that's
coming is it's a question authoring
function so given that piece of text
answer the question what is a rhinoceros
horn made of and this one I think is
going to work because I tried it before
and this should work faster than that
but anyway it's it's some it's trying to
okay so it told us based on based on
that passage of text it said it figured
out that around oestrus one is made of
keratin which i think is correct let's
ask it what the top three things that
thought a rhinoceros horn might be made
of and well that's not quite as
convincing but those are the things that
it picked out from the natural language
from that small chunk of natural
language that it picked out as the
possible answer to our own oestrus horn
is made of X but this is again another
application of machine learning it's
using lots of it's it's used a large
data set that it's learnt kind of
patterns of English from to be able to
do that okay so another thing that's
happening is being able to do very large
scale machine learning training using
AWS and using [ __ ] and so on being able
to do huge terabyte training sets and so
on and having a good workflow for doing
things like that I might mention that
something we've really been looking at
is how to document workflows we document
functions in more from language but how
do you document a workflow that goes
between while you're typing something on
your desktop computer and then you go
and you type something and you know into
a something in AWS and then either this
new you do that so we have a new form of
documentation that will be arriving
actually
next few weeks which is workflow
documentation and this is kind of this
is a typical said workflow documentation
that looks something like this typically
there'll be a tab at the top that says
what does it look like on the cloud what
does it look like in mobile and so on so
this is a new form of documentation
that's convenient for documenting these
workflow processes that aren't just type
this function get this result it's it
sort of allows us to to document a
complete workflow that involves multiple
systems and so on okay here's something
something we can do with that let me
show you very quickly and really this is
linked to unity so Unity game engine so
I can go ahead this this is something
that would typically be documented in a
workflow how to do this this should be
opening unity here let's go ahead and
open it um and oh come on that's okay
now we started this will be part of the
workflow telling us what to do in unity
okay so now we create a new project in
unity and then we can say that's going
to just create a project here okay
that's unity starting up and then okay
okay okay very good right so there's our
project in unity and now we can go ahead
here and we often language and we can
say for example create a Unity game
object so put a sphere into that unity
scene so there we go there's the Unity
game object represented in wolfmann
language and now if we look here oops
there's a sphere that appears in the
unity in the Unity game okay so now if
we wanted to we could be a little bit
fancier we could say let's get a manager
sponge let's put that in the unity game
then let's say okay let's put that in
the unity game here and then there's
that there's the game object in and well
from language there it is now in the
game and we could go ahead and give
physics to these things and have them
bounce around in the game and we can
think of unity as being kind of a an
alive form of interface to a lot of what
happens in one language if you if you
want to use it that way so the game
interface too often language okay
another thing related to this that we're
doing is system
a long-standing product of ours is we
are deeply integrating that with Wolfram
language and so that will allow us to
represent sort of a new class of things
in the language that is devices and
machines that's not a good sign maybe I
have to actually start system modeler to
make this work so let's see I think
right now maybe I have to start system
modeler I shouldn't have to start this
ok
let's um let's go here let's try that
again um so what I should get that's
even worse
okay anybody got a good idea how to make
this work what do we just move on what's
that I think so yeah ok well didn't work
ok that's a shame well what I could have
shown you is representing devices and
systems engineering systems and so on
directly Morphin language as symbolic
objects and being able to manipulate
them and do computations with them so
it's kind of a a new area for for us to
compute with ok
um another another direction I'll talk
very quickly about user interface kinds
of things one of the big emphases we've
had is on user assistance that is how
can you make it easy for people to type
in correct things and easy to show
people when they're making a mistake so
here for example notice that that time
sign that appeared at the end of the
line that's probably a mistake but it's
telling you that this is going to be
interpreted as 8 times 9 or for example
if I type something like this again
we'll get a time sign in the middle of
those you probably wanted a comma there
but it's kind of reminding you that
actually this really is going to be
treated like multiplication so we've got
a lot of things like this that we've
been steadily adding to make it easier
along with syntax colouring and auto
completion and so on to make it easier
to type correct code here's another
thing this is something convenient in
using notebooks so function called icon
eyes so this is a way of just putting a
bunch of data into a notebook so here I
just have this data and I can say show
me the length of this or something and
this is just a way of representing this
is just a list of a million
just represented by that blob and that's
a convenient thing to store in your
notebook that blob so you don't have to
you can put all the data in your
notebook but you don't get to see it you
don't have to see the whole the whole
million elements there okay so in
addition to a new user interface in um
in the desktop there's also a new user
interface in the cloud so here for
example I can show you this is this is a
nice new as its coming actually very
soon this is the nice nice new file
browser in the cloud that allows one to
do all kinds of good things here we've
got all sorts of nice options and you
can drag this thing around it's a it's a
very beautiful file browser we have sort
of different constraints because on the
desktop we don't need to build our own
file browser because that already comes
with the operating system in the cloud
we have to build our own file browser
and this is it it's it's it's nice ok so
another thing that's coming is the
ability to build kind of complete
applications complete web applications
directly from the language both the kind
of a panel language for specifying all
the different panels and making it so
that that whole that whole user
interface I just showed you could be
written just in symbolic top-level
Wolfen language code part of what's
necessary for that is the thing we call
interface switched which is a interface
wrapper that allows for responsive
design and that makes use of knowing
what what the environment in which
something finds itself is and it can be
compiled into pure CSS for the web and
so on ok another big new thing is
presenter tools so let me try and show
you that so this is a this is now a way
of creating presentations that really
work nicely in in notebooks and so on so
you can pick your theme you can pick
your theming colors I don't know let's
pick that one you can pick your your
default fonts and you say okay create a
create a presentation okay so I have
sort of sample content in this
presentation once I've got the content
that I want I could start you know I can
start editing this content I could put
in a you know a title a new title here
etc etcetera etcetera and then I can say
start the press
tation and now it will go to fullscreen
and I'm ready to roll and I can do what
I want to do here and I'm just um I'm I
can set what the keys I want to use to
to to do my my computations but unlike
something like PowerPoint this is a live
thing that you can actually type into
and do computations with and so on so
I'll show you one example of that this
was a this was the thing that I just
actually this last weekend indulging my
hobby of history of science I happened
to be at a conference and I I made up
very quickly this some this presentation
and now I've got to I've got this
presentation it's got a manipulator in
it and I can run there I can do
computations here and I've got something
but now I can go to the next slide if I
want to here's the next slide whatever
it might be what is this next slide and
it should be running what is it doing
there let's find out what the very what
the next slide is okay that was the next
slide just some images but of course
this is all still an active notebook
here so I can if I want to make the
image is bigger for people I can do that
and so on but this is still kind of all
kind of PowerPoint style in terms of
being able to to walk through it but
then then there's a manipulate and you
can you can actually it's it's an active
thing and so on so this is this is our
new presenter tools system that we think
will be really useful for people to to
present with woven language let's see
another new thing is our chat system so
here let's see I can say new chat and I
should be able to have a chat window
that comes up I hope this is now a sort
of a chat that anybody can connect to
that's a really bad sign that's a really
bad sign the well who knows
yeah I can try one I'll try one more
version here um here let's try this
um I think this is unlikely to work but
we'll try it anyway let's try that so
we're going to so what's important about
chat is it gives you it gives you this
thing that looks like an SMS kind of
chat window and people can just take
Wolfram language code or graphics or
whatever else and just run it and put it
into chat this is useful if you if
you're running a class or something
every student can be on chat and they
can send you results that will arrive in
your chat window it's a very flexible
thing it can be one-to-one many-to-one
one-to-many etc and we have a chat
system set up for this conference that
people can play with and I'm just going
to rush forward here the another thing
that's that's part of this you can you
can trivially make you can interact with
chat programmatically so you can make
chat BOTS and so on another thing I
might mention in the cloud collaborative
editing will be coming rather soon so
that you can have multiple people all
writing into the same notebook
initially in different cells in the
notebook
another thing will be coming in the
cloud so you can use chat across both
desktop and cloud and so we're building
a thing we call in probably will be
called planet-wide instant help or might
be called public help for our open cloud
where people who are using the open
cloud can ask for help and some somebody
who's volunteering can can offer them
help through this chat mechanism
another thing that's coming is SMS
messaging directly from the language
okay let me show you a completely
different thing I'm really racing
through a lot of things here let me show
you a completely different piece of the
world this is sort of an external
interaction now with blockchain so this
is showing this is connecting to the
Bitcoin blockchain that's showing the
current state let's look at the most
recent block that went onto the Bitcoin
blockchain so there it is and those are
the transactions that happened in the
Bitcoin blockchain there's a bunch of
transactions that just happened in the
latest block added to the Bitcoin
blockchain that's a lot of transactions
and then we could for example let's say
let's take the
of that Bitcoin blockchain let's get
those transactions let's so this was a
big long list again and those are that
the hashes for the transactions we could
say for example let's get the actual
data from one of those transactions okay
so there it is and we can see all the
various operations that are going on
here well so that's on the on the public
Bitcoin blockchain we can now sort of
symbolically do computations based on
the on the symbolic Bitcoin blockchain
we also have our own blockchain running
in our cloud and so this is now showing
this will show the the basic data on our
blockchain so we can just go ahead and
say let's put something into our
blockchain so let's put a picture of a
circle into our blockchain and there's
the hash that comes back from that
transaction and now if I want to I can
say get from our blockchain the thing
based on that hash and there's our
circle back again and so now if I wanted
to I can say show me the transaction
data from that transaction on our
blockchain and there's the results and
it's showing us all the various
operations that were performed to put
that data onto our blockchain and so on
so what what we'll be doing is we have
one version of the blockchain running in
our cloud private clouds will also have
block chains that the capability if you
have multiple private clouds you can
distribute the blockchain across
multiple private clouds will also
probably provide a kit for being able to
distribute our blockchain to things that
aren't necessarily even running private
clouds so this is a way of using
blockchain capability for making
Ledger's and things like this actually
welcome language is very well-positioned
to be sort of the language for smart
contracts not least because we have lots
of data about the world that can tell
you whether something has happened in
the world but we're also we were able to
express a lot of things in the world
that need to be put in contracts we're
working towards one of my big projects
is what I call symbolic discourse
language being able to express things
about the world all kinds of things
about the worlds in a symbolic language
so that you can write contracts not just
in English but in code and you'll be
able to often take existing English
language contracts and do natural
language understanding just like we do
in more malphur and turn them into
symbolic code
that can then be executed automatically
by machine okay so we want to express
lots of kinds of things in Wolfram
language so one longtime thing that I've
been interested in so that's kind of
everyday stuff let's go from the
everyday to the much more obscure one
thing I've been interested in is
representing mathematics the higher
mathematics and mathematical proofs this
is a page from the new kind of science
book this is a part of the proof I found
the simplest axiom system for boolean
algebra about 20 years ago that's part
of the automated proof of that result
well we can go ahead and take we can now
we'll be able to emotion language
directly generate something that
represents that proof so here what I'm
doing I'm taking that little tiny axiom
system for boolean algebra which I'm
kind of proud of the fact that it is the
simplest you know from the nobody will
ever find a simple one because you can
prove it's the simplest and now what I'm
doing here is I'm saying prove the
commutativity of the nand operator on
the basis of that axiom system for
boolean algebra and what I'll get here
is this thing that represents the result
of that represents that proof and so we
now the issue is how do you represent a
proof so this is now a data set that
represents so there are a hundred and
two steps these are various lemmas and
the proof and you can go ahead and look
in more detail at each lemma here this
is representing all these proofs so for
example we can say show me the proof
network here and there's a proof network
that shows me how those lemmas are
connected together what lemma refers to
what other lemma to prove things in the
proof of that result and we could also
say just show me something that will
convince me that it's true so this is
now a pure function that probably would
be formatted differently in the end but
there's a peel function which we can
just take this thing there's just a
bunch of transformation rules we can say
take that function in this case apply it
to nothing and boom it says it's true
and that just verified that this proof
is correct you can go through and look
at the pieces and see that it's just
doing replacement rules to check that
the proof is correct
so that's a one coming attraction is
being able to do do proofs like this one
thing we've been doing is working with
the proof assistant system named lien
that is a way of representing way of
encoding formal
mathematical proofs and the proofs can
be more complicated than these
equational ones we're going to have a
kind of unified format for representing
these proofs and you'll be able to enter
operate between lean and whorfin
language and Mathematica and so on to do
these computations so you know when
proofs are automated the big challenge
is that they can be very hard to
understand in Wolfram Alpha we've put a
lot of effort into making our show steps
capabilities for students to understand
how computations get done but in general
when you have one of these big automated
proofs it's really hard to understand
what on earth is actually happening and
one of the issues is that what you have
to realize is that these lemmas when you
look at these lemmas it's like you have
no idea what the important what the
significance of this lemma is there's no
kind of human understandable sort of
anchor that you have to think about
these Lamas and the thing to realize is
it's very much like what happens in
these AI systems and neural networks you
look at some intermediate piece of the
neuron that and you say well it's making
an interesting distinction and that
might be a distinction that we could
have had a word for but we don't happen
to have a word for it and similarly here
this could be a famous lemma that was
discovered by Euler but it probably
isn't
it's instead just some Lemar out there
in the space of all possible lemmas and
so there's this kind of very social
societal aspect to how you build things
that are understandable in in one of
these systems so thinking about that
gets us into the question of okay well
why don't we just take the three million
theorems that have been published on the
literature of mathematics and just
curate them turns out they're about ten
thousand named ones that have any
reasonable frequency and they follow
about a zips law distribution of
frequencies but so we're interested in
kind of curating all those kinds of
things so for example you'll find in the
data repository some slightly unexpected
formal kinds of things like a general
topology entity store which has concepts
and topology and has kind of the network
of how those concepts relate and all
those kinds of things
we're generally working towards being
able to have a way to represent all
kinds of pure mathematical constructs in
the Wolfram language so we might have an
equality test right now but to represent
things in pure mathematics we need
things like asymptotically equal to and
we think we have about 6,000 parameters
in more than language right now by
adding another
thousand to 1500 we will be able to
capture essentially all of useful modern
pure mathematics in at least be able to
represent the results there okay so in a
slightly more um more basic form let's
see if this works another area that
we've been interested in is more
elementary mathematics as geometry so
this is kind of a sketchpad thing that
we've had for a while that you'll
probably see showing up as a more built
in feature of the language but what's
more interest to us right now is being
able to to represent simple geometrical
theorems so here oh great
well that's no fun there's some well I
would have expected that to work okay so
this is a this is a coming attraction
this is a way of representing the the
structure representing kind of the setup
in a geometrical theorem so this is
saying we've got geometrical points
named a and B and they're in a triangle
and as a circle through these and now
what we can do which probably won't work
here um is it did work okay so what
that's doing now is it's taking those
geometrical setups that says a triangle
ABC there's a circle through a B and C
around the point O there are always on
the midpoint of the line a to C ok so
then it says okay generate examples
generic examples that don't have any
extra relations but generic examples of
that geometry okay so these are kind of
like show me examples that satisfy that
set up okay so then we can say okay well
given that let's just take one of those
and let's say find me kind of facts
based on that set up find me find
geometric conjectures based on this
geometric setup so it in fact discovers
that the angle between those points is
90 degrees and so on or I could for
example say let's let's generate as many
of these as we can let's see what we get
okay so here we have a couple of
different results that can be
illustrated here that come out from
generating from the from the underlying
geometric setup now of course it makes
it a lot easier to do this that we have
very power
for algebraic computation capabilities
underneath that allow us to know what's
true in an algebraic level that we can
then apply to this geometry okay another
thing that's coming oh gosh
lots of things coming in in sort of the
math area another one is closer
integration with tech just like you
can't write control equals to do natural
language you'll have a similar way of
being able to enter tech directly into
notebooks and have it rendered there
let's see this there's another thing
that's coming is numbers with
uncertainty this is another useful thing
so if we say we're not sure about the
name around we've been agonizing about
this for a long time but it's around 12
but with an error of 0.1 4 so that's 12
plus or minus 0.4 I can take that to the
fourth power it will propagate the
errors correctly for example if I do it
symbolically I can say mu plus or minus
Sigma I could take let's say something
like the square root of that I get a
result I could say take something with
an asymmetric error I could compute with
that things get much more complicated
when you're dealing with correlated
errors this is something which didn't
work in this case oh well okay Wow well
that shows that it's complicated inside
the this is okay so that's a symbolic
version of a second-order error
computation for a function f of mu okay
so that's a talking of there's a another
thing that's happening in is a
sophisticated type system for our
language where we'll be able to deeply
integrated with our with our pattern
system talking about abstract things
I'll just show one little abstract
functions kind of fun which is the curie
function you know there's a function
that in principle we could have
introduced 30 years ago but I don't
think anybody would have understood it
30 years ago I think now was sort of
increased understanding of functional
programming and expressed increased
experience with whorfin language this
function actually starts to make sense
if I say curry of FA and then I apply
that to B it will give me F of BA why is
that useful where you can say something
like curry partition four and that will
give you kind of a function which when
applied to
let's say this the alphabet will make it
partitioned in in blocks of four okay
another sort of abstract thing that's
coming is quantum computing framework so
this is a representation of a quantum
discrete state we have a representation
of a quantum circuit here obviously we
are merely simulating these quantum
computations on a classical computer I'm
not sure quantum computers really
actually exist but we can still do all
sorts of interesting formalism with them
and maybe we'll be able to connect to a
quantum API if anybody actually lets you
know delivers one that is real but this
is what's interesting here is that this
is actually very similar in the way that
it's structured with these quantum
discrete operations to the way that with
structure and neural network
computations and the same kind of
evolution from this kind of things with
wires to things with functional
programming will happen here with with
quantum computing - okay talking a
faster computation which quantum
computing may not ever deliver but a
very big effort of ours that's been
running for a long time very important
is building a full compiler for from
language so let me show you a little bit
about that so here I can let's go there
on a second let me okay so let me say
okay so I'm going to I have to tell it
right now that I need the compiler so
now what I can do here is I can say
compile this function so this is a very
simple function whether this just
showing a little bit of our type system
this is saying it's a typed lambda
expression with tight real 64 very
low-level type there but now I can just
take that thing and apply that compiled
function to something and I'll get the
results now that all looks trivial but
here's where it starts to be non-trivial
this is compiling into LLVM low-level
virtual machine language and so there's
the LLVM code for that thing and I can
take that lrvm code and I can say well
let's do a more non-trivial version
let's let's make the LLVM code for a
table here this will be probably a
somewhat complicated piece of code okay
so this is all kinds of low-level stuff
with setting pointers into registers and
all kinds of all kinds of funky stuff
okay well that's that's all well and
good let's do something else here let's
let's load in some
rules that we need now let's say let's
turn that thing into assembly language
and so this is that is the sampler
language code that came from from
Wolfram language code we're directly
generating assembler language through
LLVM that you can then run in fact stand
alone in on your machine so there's
there's a similar language for those who
can still read that stuff and if you
want it to let's be a little bit more
exotic let's target it for linux arm
instead of targeting it for x86 which is
what this machine is so there's the Lynx
arm assembly code that you could run on
a phone or something directly as a
standalone program so what we'll be
doing is having a runtime library so
some of this will run pure standalone
completely compiled into machine code
some of it will require runtime library
we'll have a variety of runtime
libraries that support different levels
of capability but what's important about
this is it will run incredibly fast so
even if you write you know one of the
issues that's been the case in wolf 9
which for a long time if you write for
time like code and wellton language
doesn't run particularly fast it will
now run blindingly fast and so we'll be
able to you know what when you run when
you write code that really uses
functional programming uses their
high-level constructs it already runs
fast but when you you will be able to
run any kind of code at kind of machine
code speed and that means that we will
actually be able to compile a lot of the
things that we a lot of Wolfram language
is now written in woven language itself
and all of all from alpha is written in
Morton language so this compiler will
allow us to make all of that a lot
faster so that's a I think it's a pretty
exciting thing that's coming this will
relate also to various kinds of
standalone deployment mechanisms and the
standalone microkernel that we're
building etc etc etc okay so lots of
stuff going on so one of the issues is
always how to present this how to
deliver information about this something
that's kind of unique to our language I
think is that one can do interesting
live code in one can actually stand here
and write code have interesting things
happen and increasingly I think live
coding is a great sort of way of
communicating what's going on one of the
mechanisms that we've been using to to
communicate live coding is we've been
I've got this um as we've been using a
platform called twitch which is really
no I did not need to sign up for the
twitch beta thank you very much um the
it's it's a platform but it's actually
built for people watching people play
video games which is arguably is one of
those human activities that if you've
gone back even a hundred years and asked
somebody whether people would ever be
doing that they would have said no
that's not that's not a conceivable
thing that could have a purpose but the
world moves forward and and there are
new purposes that emerge but in a case
we've been using twitch as a platform
for doing live coding and I've done it a
bunch I my approach is whenever I just
have some random piece of code to write
at some random time late at night or
something if it's something I think
might be of any interest to the outside
world us just start live streaming it on
twitch and so for example I've been
working on making comparing companion
notebooks for the nks book taking old
code from 20 years ago and finding out
that it still runs and cleaning it up
and doing things with it and I've been
doing a bunch of that live on Twitch and
I think it will be at the end of it I'll
have sort of the the knowledge about how
this code was made as well as as well as
the actual code because there'll be
videos of it from twitch another thing
we just started doing actually a week or
so ago is something living very
dangerous that we're kind of going into
reality TV of some sort which is we we
do what I spend a lot of my time doing
is design reviews trying to figure out
how should all this functionality that
we're building above language actually
work I think design reviews are a pretty
interesting thing because they really
you have to really get to the heart of
how some particular piece of
functionality is going to work I thought
it'd be interesting I think they're
interesting so I thought what the heck
let's live stream some design reviews so
we've now had about three episodes so
you can you can find out how those
various decisions actually got made I
think there's one about male searching
there's one about chemistry and there's
one about something else I now forget
and well we're we like feedback on these
things but we expect to continue doing
it it's a sort of an interesting way of
presenting the process of designing
well from language and designing
software in general it's kind of a live
stream design reviews okay well as you
can tell we've got a very complicated
set of things going on big big pipeline
of R&D we kind of pride ourselves on on
having clean design for the things we
produce from our R&D we also want that
we want to have clean design not only
for the our products but also for our
product line and we have this sort of
beautifully unified set up across
desktop and cloud and servers and
embedded and so on the thing we're
calling our hyper architecture and and
it's also we want sort of actual things
that people can use whether they're open
or community systems or real commercial
products they're all part of this hyper
architecture I will really be
emphasizing this kind of unification
over the coming year the first big step
in this is what we call wool from one
and wool from one is kind of our our
on-ramp into our whole technology stack
it goes across desktop and cloud and
it's kind of a new base product you can
use it in the cloud you can download a
desktop version actually soon there's
going to be a new robust download
manager so it's easier to get that full
download to happen and so if you're
doing sort of standard technical
computing or mathy kinds of things
Mathematica is the right product and all
the licensing of Mathematica is sort of
optimized for that for other things
including kind of data science software
development machine learning lots of
emerging areas well from one is really
the place to start with that because
it's set up to be able to have data
repositories and all kinds of other
things that are very useful for that and
then the idea is for more fun there's
sort of a seamless way to get to all
parts of our hyper architecture whether
you're using HPC or deploying private
clouds building up big enterprise
systems and so on it's kind of a
seamless thing that starts with well
from one so and from the cyber
architecture we're also going to be
building up a lots of vertical products
with interfaces optimized to particular
workflows where the whole thing is just
defined by a little piece of often
code actually I think it's a sort of
unique and fantastic opportunity with
Walton language that that that you can
do all of this and I think there's a lot
of opportunities for people probably
including people here to kind of build
the first generation of verticalized
products in a bunch of different areas
okay so at the other end of the scale
from big enterprise verticalized
products
there's things we're doing with K
through 12 education in general we're
doing a lot with teaching computational
thinking in fact we have a specific
product called Walton programming lab
which is sort of optimized for for
presentation there and you know the
turns out I have discovered that kids
don't notice the subtle syntax coloring
that we have so it's brighter and an
easier to notice there and there all
kinds of other detailed changes like
that that are made to deploy things in a
good way for kids but we have we have
this great opportunity with welcome
language with to teach computational
thinking because we've really automated
the whole system to the point where kids
can readily use it and it's got all that
knowledge already built into it so one
can immediately apply it to things that
are actually interesting it it's not
something where when thinking about
using welcome languages like it's coding
it's really computational thinking I
mean coding is a low-level sort of
specific engineering activity that
involves setting up loops and defining
values for variables and things like
this and it's something which you know
there's a risk that people find coding
as sort of boring as the more mechanical
aspects of math I think what we can do
with welcome language is really let
people do computational thinking
let them do interesting things
immediately with computation and so it's
it's something that ton that I'm very
keen on I've often talked about the fact
that for every field X of human endeavor
from sort of I don't know archaeology
agriculture to zoology or something
there either is now a computational X or
soon will be and that's going to be sort
of the future of those fields and that's
the thing that people need to learn is
this computational thinking that's
relevant to all of these different
computational X and something goes all
the way across the curriculum it's not
something that's a specific oh there's
this computation component of the
curriculum it's something which should
be part of the whole curriculum
computation should be something you do
in language learning language arts or
learning all sorts of other kinds of
things so one of the things that's
interesting is there's sort of a new
form of output for for students which is
what I call computational essays and
let's see the here's an example I hope
let's see if I can bring this up here's
an example of so the idea of a
computational essay is that it's just a
way of we go here's a typical
computational I say that I oh this is
just a draft of one that I wrote so the
idea is there's a little piece of text
it's very much like we've been writing
things about even from the first
mathematical book and certainly now in
my elementary introduction it's like
there's little piece of text that
explains something then it sort of
operates as a dialogue between you and
the computer of okay here's the thing
that's going to happen here's what the
has the piece of code here's what
happens and so on you go through and you
build up some concept through this
computational essay and I think this is
a great form of output from students and
so on trying to you know express their
understanding of something it's kind of
the it's like where you could write an
English essay but you can also write a
computational essay the computational
essay it has a lot more leverage you can
do a lot more original things here
because you're sort of collaborating
with the computer and getting it done
actually it's sort of interesting so and
these are just notebooks we have one new
style that helps support a code text
style that helps support these kinds of
things so these are great for kids
they're also computational essays are a
great way to explain things in general
actually our plan is to make a way you
can deploy these things the web our plan
is to make a big encyclopedia of of of
computational essays kind of
explorations of topics of all different
kinds of things and these will be
deployed on the web in such a way that
you can not only read them but also
actually interact with them in our open
cloud and so the idea is that you know
we've got
1,000 demonstrations we hope we will
have at least as many topic explorations
I hope people here will be able to
contribute to that I think we have a
place where you can submit there's a
description of how to write a topic
exploration and you can submit it
directly in the cloud here and the idea
is to make a big sort of giant
encyclopedia of topic explorations about
everything one might be interested in so
we yeah it's one of the things that's
interesting about computational essays
as it's something for kids is one thing
about a computational essay is it's
actually useful even a long time after
you wrote it that is I you know back a
hundred years or something ago when kids
learn math they did it by writing these
so-called ciphering books where they
would over a course of years
write out kind of examples of solutions
to particular kinds of math problems
that might occur in later life and then
they would keep these ciphering books as
kind of a reference for how do you do
percentage increase or or whatever else
well most of what people do in school
these days they kind of just do it as an
exercise and that's gone but these
computational essays if you wrote
something out that you understood at
some point and you keep it you'll be
able to run that code many years from
now and and have it be a useful
reference for the future so I think
that's sort of an interesting extra
feature of computational essays so
beyond computational essays another sort
of thing is being able to produce
courses we have Wolfram you that we've
been rolling out that's kind of us
producing courses about all kinds of
different things that we are looking
forward to contributions from people
here's kind of an example of how some of
these courses work this is one based on
my elementary introduction to open
language there's a video there's text
here there's also if I can figure out
how to do it there is also oh yeah try
section which actually has some content
the okay that's not good but anyway we
can here you can enter this is probably
the worst section to try of all but
let's try
it's tried a different section here the
so this is some a these are exercises
here and then we can say what's the
expected output from that exercise or we
can say click to enter code and then we
get a place where we can enter code and
we have a pretty sophisticated auto
grading system which we'll try and
figure out whether the piece of code
that you entered is correct I don't know
what's going wrong here this is probably
still some test version but anyway this
gives some sense of what's happening we
have a bunch of tools for making these
videos and tools for setting up this
whole whole framework here for building
courses and I encourage people to look
at doing that
there's Wolfram Media are publishing
operation is publishing general interest
educational material both in book form
and in the form of an in online forms
like this so let's see the I think
there's always a question you know
modern computational thinking is
something I think is sort of critical to
teach this sort of a question of what
the curriculum should look like people
keep on asking me this and I I probably
will actually end up writing out a
fairly detailed kind of curriculum and
which may turn into sort of a book about
sort of concepts and applications of
modern computation that tries to tries
to address this so a lot more that we're
doing in in an education in K through 12
we have a thing we're calling out
computational thinking initiatives CTI
we've had our very successful CBM
initiative that started with math
education and that's steaming forward we
have some other angles as well we've had
our summer school that is sort of
primarily for adults and we've also had
summer school consists of people make
all sorts of interesting projects this
might be you know what I think this web
browser is becoming extremely bloated I
think that is our problem here look at
that look at all those tabs I think come
I think that's some let's bring this
thing back to life let's say oops that's
not what I wanted let's say
um okay let's see though maybe this is a
tumbler from this let's see this this
should this should bring up just
examples of projects that we're done at
our summer school
I hope waiting for okay there we go
there's just a bunch of bunch of
projects there tons and tons of these
they're kind of interesting to see um
but we both had this summer summer
school for adults and also our summer
camp for high school kids but don't tell
me the network has failed again that's
just weird
any case the okay and we can see some of
the projects that have been done by
those those kids I hope but any case one
of the things we're trying to do is to
take that sort of two-week experience of
going from zero to being able to do a
non-trivial computational thinking
project and package it in a variety of
different ways and we're sort of
building what we are calling our AI
League clubs and a kind of AI art and
science fair as a way of presenting
these things why does it say it can't be
reached this as tumblr should be able to
be reached anyway there's some examples
from our current summer school the goal
is to widely be able to let kids learn
how to do stuff like this and there all
sorts of fun and interesting
opportunities around that another thing
we're doing small thing we're doing is
some our challenges website this isn't
quite ready but it will be soon
these are Wolfram language challenges
that you can do and there are
leaderboards and so on for them
something that's kind of interesting
around around Wolfram language okay so
finally um yeah it sort of brings me to
our big challenge which is okay we're
doing all this stuff and we've got all
these different things that we've been
building in our technology stack how do
we communicate everything that we have
how do we really make sure that everyone
who should be using what we have
actually is I have to say that it's it's
for me it's quite frustrating as I sort
of travel around I hear the same thing
all the time which is you guys have all
this amazing stuff
how come more people aren't using it
well you can't always tell who's using
it they're actually plenty of people
using technology stack increasingly in
large-scale production environments
where you actually don't know what's
underneath this large-scale production
environment but that clearly should be
and could be orders of magnitude more
usage of what we built and our sort of
goal is to - we built out a lot in the
last few years kind of our deployment
capabilities so that you can take this
core wealth and language technology and
deploy it across all these different
environments that's kind of one step the
other step is actually making sure that
people really internalize and understand
how they can make use of what we have
and you guys here are kind of the
vanguard of that some of you for many
years some of you just recently but you
know our challenge to sort of get the
word out better and of course there are
lots of opportunities that come with our
technology stack building a product
based on our technology starting a
company building a new field of research
I mean one day eventually what we have
here will be quite ubiquitous and all of
the stuff we've done with
knowledge-based computation will be
taken for granted will be just a layer
that gets taken for granted but right
now a lot of what we can do kind of
looks to most people like magic I mean
you guys sort of understand the magic
and you know the message is make use of
it
you know I'm I'm very proud of what we
built with welcome language and
everything around it but to realize that
potential really needs the help of lots
of people including including people
here so I mean no I know many of you
were already involved in doing lots of
things with our technology and thank you
for that but there's also a lot more to
do and I hope you will choose to get
involved I mean I think actually I think
we had see a survey after about
different different ways that we know of
that that people can get involved with
with things that we're doing I think
what we're doing is pretty important I
mean I think computation is kind of the
great new paradigm of our times and you
know we've been lucky enough to build
what I think is kind of the definitive
technology stack that lets computation
really achieve its potential
in the world and now we have to really
get that technology stack deployed
everywhere it can be and to actually do
what I think should happen and to make
it this kind of ubiquitous layer in the
technology world I think when this has
happened it's going to be seen as a
quite historic thing that has occurred
over the course of the years in which it
occurs and you know I hope I hope as
many of you as possible will will choose
to be involved it's kind of fun being
involved in historic kinds of things and
I think we've got one of these that's
kind of right on the cusp of of being
very ubiquitous and important so I
encourage you to be there and I should
wrap up now on I'm sorry I've gone for
such a long time I had you could tell I
had a fair amount to talk about thanks
for much
[Applause]
you
[Applause]